and now a special look at marvel sung qi  in theaters everywhere tonight  okay let's get you ready to fight wait  what well multi-platform global  operation every fight live stream on the  dark web thousands of viewers placing  beds as we speak this is gonna take your  brand to a whole new level i think  there's been some sort of confusion i  like your spike face they're my guts  usually you gotta fight your way to  central ring but viral style like you  found a line baby i'm not here to fight  anybody okay i'm looking for my sister  she's charlene  never heard of her we just lost a fight  at the last minute so you get the next  slot  nice one helen  is he anybody in one of these  oh no no no no these are like low level  fights you're  gonna be fighting  up  marvel there shangqi and the legend of  the ten rings be the first to experience  it tonight